quentin tarantino's made a lot of great
movies but which one ranks as the very
best let's take a look back through his
entire filmography and find out which
classics reign supreme
if you ever want to learn everything you
need to know about independent
filmmaking in the 90s but you only have
two hours to do it watch 1995's four
rooms it's a bizarre little artifact of
the era an anthology involving four
up-and-coming directors with each
segment set in a different room of the
same hotel all united by a single
character ted the bellhop the hapless
high-strung bellhop played by 90s indie
mainstay tim roth a coven of witches
not an oven
well one which in particular tarantino
was the biggest filmmaker involved
having just come off the massive
mainstream success of pulp fiction and
as a result he got the prime spot as the
writer and director of the movie's final
segment the man from hollywood it's not
bad either with tarantino loosely
adapting roald dahl's man from the south
once used as one of the better episodes
of alfred hitchcock presents as a
fast-talking farce that skips out on the
chills of the original in favor of a
snappy punchline about ted making the
most of his increasingly surreal evening
the problem is it's not great either
it's perfectly fine but it plays up
tarantino's tendency toward references
and homages and winds up feeling pretty
slight especially when it's compared to
other segments in the film
natural born killers is really only a
tarantino film on a technicality he
wrote the original screenplay but by the
time oliver stone finished his version
of the hyper-violent satire of mass
media and mass murder so much had been
changed that tarantino only received a
story credit and barely acknowledges it
as one of his movies at the end of the
day stone found himself far more
interested in the way that media
sensationalized murder and violence in
real life stories than the
straightforward crime story tarantino
wrote as a result the movie was rebuilt
as a full-on satire tarantino's love of
over-the-top violence is still there as
is a lot of the dialogue but
thematically it's a very different beast
the end result is a film that's well
made and extremely compelling but that's
also not really a tarantino movie in any
way that really matters
for a movie that's meant to be about
fast cars crashing into each other death
proof is extremely slow there are
seemingly endless fairly pointless
conversations that pad out the movie
between the two big car chases and they
make the film feel longer than it is for
a movie released in 2007 it seems to
bounce back and forth between ponderous
narrative and lurid high concept but for
good or ill that's all on purpose when
tarantino and robert rodriguez set out
to pay tribute to the groundhouse double
features of the 70s with grindhouse
tarantino's half was just a note perfect
recreation of those movies warts and all
it's not just talky and violent it's
talky and slow in the same way that
films like two-lane blacktop and
vanishing point were talky and slow and
that twist ending where the horror movie
suddenly becomes a hilarious slapstick
revenge movie that's pure tarantino
having a ton of fun sadly it's just not
quite as fun for the audience as we'd
like it to be the hateful eight should
be amazing it has an incredible cast
that reunites tarantino with some of the
all-stars he'd worked with previously
while also throwing newcomers like
channing tatum into the mix for good
measure
banging desperate men in their lives a
good way to get yourself dead
can't catch me sleeping if i don't close
my eyes
the stage was set for an incredibly
tense thriller that would inevitably
build tarantino's signature brutal
violence complete with a third act twist
that blew the locked room mystery
element wide open and changed everything
in practice however the hateful eight
was disappointing despite featuring some
of the most charismatic actors in the
business the paper-thin characters
outlived their welcome far before the
movie stumbled to the end of its
three-hour run time the tension that's
baked into the story by bottling up a
bunch of suspicious characters wound up
collapsing under its own weight and
evaporating turning the hateful eight
into a thriller that just didn't have
any thrills
jackie brown is unquestionably
tarantino's most underrated film and to
be honest it's pretty easy to see why
for one thing it had to follow pulp
fiction and for another it's so
different from his other films that it
can't help but seem like the one that
doesn't quite fit there's no
over-the-top violence and it lacks the
non-linear storytelling he'd become
known for at that point and perhaps the
most unusual for tarantino it stands as
the only time that he's adapted a novel
elmer leonard's rum punch for the screen
but that's also what's great about it
with jackie brown tarantino showed that
he could tell a slightly more focused
smaller crime story that didn't
necessarily have to sprawl out into a
non-linear epic as much as it might not
seem like it goes with the others
there's a good reason that it's
leonard's favorite adaptation of his own
work
when they get it right quentin tarantino
and his friend robert rodriguez can mesh
their styles into action movie
perfection and nowhere is that better
illustrated than in from dusk till dawn
directed by rodriguez with a script by
tarantino also stars alongside george
clooney and juliet lewis it follows a
pair of bank robbers who hijack a
faithless pastor and his family in an
effort to get across the border in
mexico then they wind up at a strip club
staffed entirely by vampires as you
might have guessed from that setup it's
ridiculously over the top even by
tarantino standards in other words it's
fun
even better it manages to showcase some
of the best of what both filmmakers had
to offer with rodriguez's spectacular
visual sensibilities taking center stage
alongside tarantino's compelling
characters and memorable dialogue even
though he didn't direct it true romance
couldn't feel more like an early
tarantino film with all the signature
moves that you'd expect to see there's
the way that the story follows two
hapless love struck criminals as they
wind up involved in a crime that goes
way over their heads there's a cast of
engaging supporting characters who feel
like they could have an entire movie all
to themselves it's even got a truly
brutal climactic fight scene between
patricia arquette and james gandolfini
that feels like the prototype for what
you'd see later and kill bill
and just in case all that wasn't
tarantino enough for you there's also a
scene where the two main characters talk
about how great sunny chiba is that said
director tony scott did convince
tarantino to change the ending to
something a little happier something
that almost led the writer to take his
name off the film so while it's full of
tarantino ideas
it's not quite pure tarantino
looking at it on paper once upon a time
in hollywood seemed like a pretty dicey
proposition from pretty much every angle
it was a movie about movies and while
you could say that about every tarantino
flick on some level this one stripped
away the layer of being inspired by 60s
cinema and just made that the whole
focus of the film it also dealt directly
with the manson family murders and
tackling a well-known horrifying and
relatively recent tragedy as an action
comedy with tarantino's tendency toward
historical revisionism seemed like a
surefire way to make everyone mad
ah
can i help you
but if tarantino's work has shown us
anything is that you can't really
predict what it looks like when it hits
the screen and it turned out that asking
what would have happened if a washed up
actor and his stuntman buddy fought the
manson family with the flamethrower a
question none of us even ever thought to
ask made for a wildly entertaining film
to say that tarantino has always worn
his cinematic influences on his sleeve
is understating things quite a bit but
that's never been more apparent than in
the first volume of kill bill
kill bill is a synthesis of everything
that tarantino loves about hong kong
martial arts films revenge epics and
sunny chiba's street fighter saga to the
point of actually casting chiba himself
in a major role as hattori hanzo what's
really amazing though is how well this
first park stands on its own without
feeling like the first chapter of a
single movie it is some of tarantino's
best sequences including the
delightfully brutal showdown with the
crazy 88 at the house of blue leaves
it's a film that goes well beyond simple
homage and becomes something far better
than the sum of its parts
reservoir dogs isn't just a phenomenal
directorial debut it's also the
prototype for virtually everything that
quentin tarantino would be doing for
the next 25 years it's all here from the
blood-soaked suspense to the non-linear
storytelling to the characters having
hyper-obsessive conversations about pop
culture shortly before getting into
deadly situations like a virgin is not
about some sensitive girl who meets that
nice fella
that's what trouble is about no granted
no argument about that it's even got tim
roth and michael madsen who would go on
to be two of tarantino's go-to casting
choices and that soundtrack madsen
grooving to 70s classics while slicing
off a man's ear is still one of the most
iconic moments of tarantino's career
that said prototypes even great ones are
still meant to be improved upon
reservoir dogs laid down the foundation
and made tarantino an instant favorite
for critics and audiences alike but
later films would find tarantino
refining his approach and building on
what he'd already done
there's a pretty compelling argument to
be made that django unchained is quentin
tarantino's best movie it certainly has
some of the best performances including
leonardo dicaprio's turn as the truly
despicable calvin candy the really
amazing thing though is that django ends
up balancing every aspect of the story
that in lesser hands would feel
disjointed and full of tonal whiplash
it's a comedy where the gags like don
johnson is the idiot leader of an
equally stupid gang of clansmen who get
blown up with dynamite are genuinely
funny largely thanks to jimmy fox's
endlessly charming performance in the
lead role it's a revenge movie where the
bad guys are infinitely easy to hate
it's a story of love and friendship
conquering all where the romance is
genuinely stirring and where christoph
waltz is able to earn some sympathy by
playing the exact opposite of his
character in inglorious bastards in
short it's amazing but it's not quite
the best
the opening scene of inglorious bastards
where christoph waltz is charming
horrifying nazi investigator sits across
the table from a farmer offering up a
tortiously slow revelation and an
impossible choice is one of the most
tense thrilling and horrifying scenes of
the past few decades but even that's not
the best thing about this movie the
scene where brad pitt is the leader of
the bastards demands a hundred nazi
scalps and donnie the bear jew goes wild
with the baseball bat are amazing but
they're not the best thing either the
slow burn reveal with daniel brawl as a
decorated sniper who reveals that even a
polite nazi is still a nazi is a brutal
punch to the gut but that's still not
the best thing no the best thing about
bastards is that it's a world war ii
movie that manages to subvert the one
incontrovertible truth about world war
ii movies we know how they end in this
movie though it's not a self-inflicted
gunshot in a bunker that takes out
hitler it's a handful of jewish soldiers
unloading machine guns in a burning
movie theater in one hell of a great
ending
everything we already said about kill
bill volume 1 still applies to the
sequel but there's one thing that puts
the second volume ahead of the first an
emotional core that underscores the
action if the first movie's focus is on
the horrific suffering that leads the
bride on her rampage of revenge the
second is about how she chooses to
overcome it literally and figuratively
digging herself out of the grave that
bill put her into and when she actually
confronts bill their conversation and
his crucial completely appropriate
misunderstanding of how superman works
gives the characters far more depth than
any blood-drenched step-by-step revenge
movie could not that kill bill volume 2
is lacking in blood of course but it
backs it up with some incredible emotion
pulp fiction isn't just tarantino's
breakthrough hit and it's not just the
movie that defined his career it was and
is a pop culture phenomenon with an
influence that's still being felt over
two decades after its release on its own
it's the movie that made samuel l
jackson a household name resurrected
john travolta's career and proved that a
complicated crime story with a
mysterious macguffin told out of order
could be a massive mainstream success
think about how many times you've seen
someone recreate uma thurman's twist
contest moves on the dance floor are
heard tarantino's version of ezekiel 25
17 quoted in place of the actual much
shorter bible verse it's a movie that
changed pop culture forever and still
holds up as a justified classic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]